keine fans auf den rängen kein jubel im
stadion die olympischen spiele zum
ersten mal ohne zuschauer in tokio gilt
der korona ausnahmezustand paradoxe lage
in den impfzentren obwohl immer mehr
impfstoff da ist bekommen weniger
menschen die spritze gegen kuwait 19 und
millionenstrafen für volkswagen und bmw
wegen illegaler absprachen bei der
abgasreinigung fordert die eu von den
autobauern 875 millionen euro
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten
donnerstagabend in aalen zum
nachrichtenüberblick heute um 7
gemeinsam mit kristin otto an einem
denkwürdigen tag für den sport in der
tat ein novum keine zuschauer in tokio
olympische wettkämpfe vor leeren rängen
kein anfeuern kein applaus so
schmerzvolles ist jetzt wird aber von
den meisten sportlerinnen und sportlern
respektiert zwei wochen vor beginn der
olympischen spiele steigt die zahl der
neuinfektionen in tokio für die stadt
gilt jetzt der gesundheitsnotstand und
so begründen organisatoren und japans
regierung auch ihre entscheidung die es
so in der geschichte der olympischen
spiele noch nie gegeben hat
eigentlich sollte olympia so aussehen
2012 beispielsweise das olympiastadion
in london jeden tag ausverkauft mit
80.000 zuschauern eine euphorie bei den
wettkämpfen die auch vor fünf jahren in
rio zu spüren war jetzt stattdessen
geisterspiele auch die meist so
prunkvolle eröffnungsfeier ohne fans es
werden definitiv andere spiele werden
martin neeson ist für uns in japan wie
blei liegen die olympia souvenirs in den
geschäften von vorfreude auf die spiele
keine spur in tokio im gegenteil die
infektionszahlen steigen wieder und mit
ihnen die skepsis der bevölkerung
ich finde es fragwürdig in einer solchen
zeit die spiele so durchzuboxen
wir sind mitten in einer pandemie das
ist es was mich die ganze zeit
beschäftigt nicht olympia aus angst vor
einer neuen welle verhängte
premierminister sogar heute zwei erneut
den ausnahmezustand über tokio von einer
absage der spiele aber sprachen nicht
die regierung glaubt den punkt zum ikea
verpasst zu haben es ist wie bei einem
spieler der viel geld verzockt hat und
nun nicht mehr stoppen kann weil er
zurückgewinnen will was er zuvor
verloren hat wenige stunden später traf
sich der präsident des ioc mit
vertretern der regierung behörden und
organisationskomitees und versprach
eilig sichere spiele
die japanische bevölkerung kann sich
glücklich schätzen dass mindestens 85
prozent der mitglieder der olympischen
delegationen geimpft in tokio ankommen
werden
geholfen hat es nicht am späten abend
die entscheidung die wettkämpfe in der
hauptstadt werden ohne publikum
stattfinden
die entscheidung ist angesichts der
pandemischen lagen nachvollziehbar für
das ioc ist es eine schwere niederlage
für die sportbegeisterte japanische
bevölkerung und die gebeutelte
wirtschaft eine katastrophe souvenir
salz ladenhüter sind da noch das
geringste problem dieser spiele von
tokio
jetzt nach deutschland wurde das impf
tempo nachlässt und das obwohl impfen
weiter wichtig bleibt im kampf gegen
korona was tun ärzte und politiker
bringen heute verschiedene vorschläge
ins spiel um das angebot unkomplizierter
zu machen und extra anreize zu bieten
schauen wir uns aber erstmal die zahlen
genauer an aktuell sind laut
gesundheitsministerium 40,8 prozent der
bevölkerung vollständig geimpft das impf
tempo schwankte zuletzt auch wegen
feiertagen und schulferien mitte juni
der vorläufige höhepunkte impfungen zur
zeit wird bundesweit wieder weniger
geimpft wohl auch weil in fünf ländern
ferien sind sibylle bassler berichtet
aus einem impfzentrum in bayern
das impfzentrum altötting in
spitzenzeiten wurden hier 1000 menschen
am tag geimpft
doch seit zwei wochen herrschte flaute
von einem anderen tag sind die
impfwilligen ausgestorben und wir hatten
auf einer impfstoffen überfluss hat sich
keiner wagen würde im moment kommen um
die 100 impflinge die warteliste
ziemlich leer der kühlschrank handvoll
mit 12.000 impfdosen biontech moderner
johnson & johnson oder astra zenica
alles vorhanden doch kaum abnehmer da es
gibt natürlich die harte gruppe die sich
nicht impfen lassen würde
die aus dem jack wertinger kreisen kommt
es gibt ganz viele die unentschlossen
sind und die die eben gefühl haben ja
ich brauche jetzt keine impfung ist
vorbei eine einstellung so die
medizinerin die hauptsächliche sache
äußern
gut 40 prozent in deutschland
vollständig geimpft die im vorläufig
viel zu langsam so die experten
es ist relativ klar dass wir eine
impfquote von 80 85 prozent brauchen um
sicher durch den herbst winter 20 21 22
zu marschieren
umso wichtiger sei es im pflüger zu
mobilisieren eine möglichkeit könnten
attraktive anreize seien zb dass man wie
in anderen ländern eine hilf lotterie
oder irgend sowas aufbaut weil es auf
jeden fall besser ist die leute zu
impfen als hinterher weder in den lock
down zu gehen in altötting schlägt man
eigene wege ein
so werden neben kreuz impfungen auch
impfungen für kinder ab zwölf angeboten
trotz fehlender empfehlung der stiko wir
schalten unseren verstand ein und sagen
das ist so richtig und wir machen das so
egal was einer münchner in berlin gesagt
damit der impfstoff nicht verfällt
können sich auch menschen aus ganz
deutschland hier einen impftermin geben
lassen
der impfstoff astrazeneca wurde ja sehr
häufig verengt wurde
denn nach der stiko empfehlung die
zweitimpfung besser mit biontech oder
moderner zu machen will ihn praktisch
niemand mehr auch nicht bei der
erstimpfung obwohl ja gerade die kreuz
impfung als sehr wirkungsvoll gilt gegen
die delta variante astrazeneca bleibt in
vielen im kühlschränken liegen und wird
oft erst gar nicht mehr bestellt oliver
deuker eine hausarztpraxis in hannover
vor allem astrazeneca kann ihr als erste
impfung zum einsatz doch jetzt mutiert
dieser impfstoff 4 und in vielen anderen
im verein richtungen zum ladenhüter
aufgrund von lieferschwierigkeiten in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten haben
wir gesagt wir bestellen schon vorab für
die zweitimpfung und dann kam die
empfehlung von der stiko dass eben diese
kreuz impfungen gemacht werden sollen
und unglücklicherweise werden wir auf
unserem astra sitzenbleiben jetzt die
patienten werden wollen alle blick haben
astrazeneca ist einfach verbrannt
das weiß auch niedersachsens
gesundheitsministerin handelt
dementsprechend wir stellen fest es gibt
einfach ein großes unbehagen daher haben
wir jetzt beim bund unsere astra zenica
lieferung für die verbleibenden juli
wochen abgestellt so dass wir den
impfstoff gar nicht mehr nach
niedersachsen bekommen gestern reagierte
auch das bundeskabinett alle weiteren
astrazeneca lieferungen werden ab august
unentgeltlich an ärmere länder abgegeben
so wird aus der not eine tugend gemacht
diese abgaben der deutschen
bundesregierung kommen leider sehr spät
und es sollte eben nicht um eine reste
teilen gehen sondern deutschland sollte
unverzüglich über die kovacs fasziniert
impfstoff dosen an die ärmeren länder
abgeben
dieser almosen der reichen denn da
können aber leider nur kurzfristig einen
beitrag leisten langfristig und für die
überwindung dieser pandemie braucht es
eben auch effektiven technologietransfer
das aus für astra weniger bleibt für
deutschland wohl ohne folgen impfstoff
wird ausreichend vorhanden sein
rund 70 millionen dosen mrn aktien
sollen bis september kommen und 50
millionen dosen werden für die noch
fehlenden erst und zweitwohnungen
benötigt
die aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland sind weiterhin niedrig das
robert koch institut meldet 970 neue
fälle innerhalb eines tages das sind 78
mehr als vergangenen donnerstag
außerdem kamen binnen 24 stunden 31
todesfälle dazu die bundesweite sieben
tage incidents steigt minimal auf 5,2
wenn man nachweisen kann dass man schon
mal corona hatte also genesen ist und
inzwischen eine impfung bekommen hat
dann kann man jetzt auch in apotheken
den digitalen impfnachweis bekommen und
zwar schon ab morgen sagt der
apothekerverband
bislang war das nicht möglich jetzt habe
man eine technische lösung gefunden und
dann heute eine ganze reihe wichtiger
nachrichten bei denen es um geld geht
viel geld erst mal eine millionenstrafe
für deutsche autobauer die hätten nach
ansicht der eu kommission die
möglichkeit gehabt schädliche abgase
deutlicher zu reduzieren
doch sie hätten sich lieber
untereinander abgesprochen dass einfach
sein zu lassen den wettbewerb zu scheuen
im kern geht es um zu kleine tanks für
den ad blut zusatz bei dieselfahrzeugen
mit der technik können abgase gereinigt
werden der vw konzern soll jetzt rund
500 millionen euro strafe zahlen bmw
mehr als 370 millionen
daimler hatte die absprachen an die eu
gemeldet und kommt deshalb als kronzeuge
ohne strafe davon
peter kunst in hannover beobachtet für
uns die deutschen autobauer so eine
kartellbuße für rein technische
vereinbarungen peter gab es noch nie in
europa was heißt das jetzt für die
betroffenen firmen außer dass sie zahlen
müssen
es bedeutet wohl dass die europäischen
wettbewerbshüter ihren kriterienkatalog
für illegale kartelle erweitert haben
gibt es sonst um preisabsprachen oder
gebiets formel 1 so spielt jetzt der
umweltgedanke eine rolle und die idee
dass innovation und fortschritt in
europa nicht durch autokonzerne
behindert werden sollen die techniken
von gestern pflegen oder neue kurz
halten novellus profit bringt während
das der umwelt andererseits schadet wenn
man so will kann man diese adblue
absprachen bis 2014/15 sind die gelaufen
eine mini diesel krise nennen mini sind
ja auch die strafen im vergleich zum
großen diesel betrug für den hat
volkswagen zum beispiel inzwischen mit
rund 32 milliarden euro büßen müssen das
in 500 millionen jetzt vergleichsweise
klein geld sagt peter kunz zdf hannover
peter vielen dank und jetzt noch eine
nachricht vom automarkt opel will ab
2028 in europa nur noch elektrische
fahrzeuge anbieten und will sich dann
auch auf dem chinesischen markt als
reine elektro marke präsentieren
zuletzt hatte opel in deutschland einen
marktanteil von gut 6 prozent
die firma will jetzt auch weiter dem
trend weiterer autobauer folgen
erfolgreiche klassiker als modelle
wieder aufleben zu lassen und dann ein
strategiewechsel in der geldpolitik den
hat die europäische zentralbank
angekündigt und sich ein neues
inflationsziel gesetzt
laut ezb chefin christine lagarde strebt
die notenbank in zukunft eine
teuerungsrate im euroraum von zwei
prozent an
jahrelang hatte das ziel anders gelautet
nämlich eine inflationsrate unter aber
nahe 2% nahe 2% zwei prozent jetzt für
laien als ziel erstmal kein so großer
unterschied valerie haller guten namen
nach frankfurt was heißt das jetzt für
uns alle konkret das heißt vermutlich
dass die zinsen auf lange sicht ultra
niedrig bleiben und sich das gute alte
sparen bis auf weiteres nicht lohnt im
gegenteil
sparer müssen sich eher noch auf
strafzinsen einrichten und auf eine
höhere inflation das ersparte wird dann
also schon gar nicht mehr sondern eher
weniger und anleger an den aktienmärkten
die dürften aufatmen die ultraniedrigen
zinsen machen
in attraktiver gegenüber anderen
anlageformen allerdings muss man auch
dazusagen besteht das risiko dass blasen
entstehen auch an den immobilienmärkten
und weil er wie welche schlüsse kann man
aus dem heutigen tag ziehen auf die
generelle künftige geldpolitik der ezb
daraus kann man ziehen dass die ezb sich
deutlich mehr flexibilität verschafft
hat sie muss nämlich nicht mehr sofort
reagieren wenn die inflation über oder
unter zwei prozent liegt künftig darf
also ruhig auch mal ein bisschen mehr
inflation sein ohne dass die
währungshüter an der zinsschraube drehen
müssen
das spielt natürlich all den ländern in
die hände die hoch verschuldet sind
ultraniedrige zinsen was heißt dass das
heißt schuldenmachen bleibt günstig das
gilt natürlich auch für privatleute die
einen kredit aufnehmen wollen
erläuterungen von valerie haller valerie
danke dir dafür unser nächstes thema
heute abend in haiti hat der
mordanschlag auf präsident erwin elmo s
gestern einmal mehr gezeigt wie schlimm
die lage im land ist der karibikstaat
ist das ärmste land amerikas und das war
schon vor dem verheerenden erdbeben 2010
so
seitdem ist haiti nicht vorangekommen
gewalt korruption und armut und auch
politisch gab es keine stabilität
präsident muss reagierte eineinhalb
jahre ohne parlament über die situation
nach seinem tod berichtet newport ein
handy video aus der tatnacht zeigte
schwer bewaffnete männer nach der
präsidentenvilla schüsse sind zu hören
ob das die attentäter oder
sicherheitskräfte sind ist nicht klar
am nächsten morgen wird die leiche von
staatspräsident movies abtransportiert
seine gattin martin wurde schwer
verletzte und inzwischen in ein
krankenhaus nach florida ausgeflogen
die attentäter er in spanisch und
englisch gesprochen so der polizeichef
bei einem feuergefecht mit der polizei
seien vier der angreifer erschossen zwei
weitere festgenommen worden
über hintergründe und identität der
männer ist noch nichts bekannt nur diese
fotos wurden veröffentlicht
regierungschef rief die bürger zur ruhe
auf und kündigte den ausnahmezustand an
alles sei unter kontrolle so josef der
flughafen wurde ebenso wie die grenzen
zur dominikanischen republik geschlossen
präsident chávez war nach umstrittenen
wahlen 2017 zum staatschef von haiti
ernannt worden
das als eines der ärmsten länder
weltweit gilt mehr als die hälfte der
elf millionen einwohner lebt unterhalb
der armutsgrenze von zweieinhalb dollar
am tag
korruption und bandenkriminalität sind
weit verbreitet 2010 erschütterte ein
schweres erdbeben haiti
fast 300.000 menschen kamen ums leben
wirtschaftlich hat sich das land seither
nicht mehr erhöht nach preiserhöhungen
waren vor zwei jahren blutige unruhen
mit zahlreichen toten ausgebrochen
die opposition hat der präsident muss
immer wieder korruption vorgeworfen und
neuwahlen gefordert
in florida haben sie rund zwei wochen
nach dem teileinsturz eines wohnhauses
die suche nach überlebenden offiziell
beendet jetzt geht es für die
einsatzkräfte dar um die opfer zu bergen
chancenlos sei es in dem schutt des
wohnturms noch überlebende zu finden
am abend nahmen angehörige und helfer in
einem stillen gedenken abschied von den
bislang 60 bestätigten opfern fast 100
menschen werden immer noch vermisst
an der unglücksstelle ins offside
erinnern fotos blumen und botschaften
ansehen und jetzt in der sendung sind
wir beim sport und bei ihr sind jetzt
drei events mit zuschauern volles haus
in wimbledon und kein happy end für
angelique kerber kein zweiter
turniersieg nach 2018 enormer kampfgeist
wurde diesmal nicht belohnt sie unterlag
der weltranglisten-erste ashley partie
aus australien in zwei sätzen
die partie konnte kerber der nummer eins
nicht verderben aber sie steigerte sich
nach 13 6 im ersten satz und setzte die
australierin mit platzierten
grundlinienschlägen unter druck nach
break und rebreak im zweiten satz lag
kerber im tie break schon 0 zu sechs
zurück wehrte drei matchbälle ab
aber im vierten blieb ihr risiko return
im netz hängen mit 6 3 und 7 zu 6 die
partie ins endspiel ein
ich glaube das match war wirklich auf
augenhöhe und es waren einzelpunkte
dieses match entschieden haben
angelique kerber verabschiedet sich nach
starker leistung und einem tollen
turnier erhobenen hauptes zwölfte etappe
der tour de france erster tagessieg für
einen deutschen radprofi nils polit aus
köln erreichte nach einem mutigen
ausreiß versuch souverän als erster das
ziel
es ist der größte erfolg für den 27
jährigen kölner der sich zwölf kilometer
vor dem ziel mit diesem antritt von
seinen mit ausreißern absetzt und danach
auf den letzten kilometern freie fahrt
hat gedacht okay dass das ist der tag wo
es probieren kann nachdem ich auch
wusste okay das sind keiner hinterher
fährt und die tour de france etappe
gewonnen was man sagen einfach
unglaublich happy
kurz vor dem ziel in ihm kann es immer
noch nicht fassen
zuvor als profi nur ein mal siegreich
gewinnt polit nun eine etappe beim
berühmtesten rennen der welt
und zur fußball-europameisterschaft
jubelstürme bei den engländern die sich
endlich den ersten finaleinzug bei einem
wichtigen turnier seit der wm 66
gesichert haben sonntagabend gegen
italien in wembley an selber stelle das
2 2 1 gestern abend gegen dänemark
durchaus umstritten
die 140 spielminute storl ihn fällt im
strafraum elfmeter schiedsrichter meckel
die ahndet den leichten kontakt an
sterling knie und hüfte die entscheidung
diskutabel aber unumstößlich so kommt es
zum siegtor durch kane und der nächsten
em partie in london
ich habe das neue wembley noch nie so
stimmungsvoll erlebt darms chor hatte
dänemark in führung gebracht nach heers
eigentor england deutlich überlegen
durch den elfmeter in der verlängerung
schließlich das halbfinal-aus für das
überraschungsteam aus dänemark fader
beigeschmack
kristin vielen dank wir haben so jetzt
von uns für sie zum schluss eine
premiere in den bayerischen alpen einer
der beiden bartgeier damen die dort
ausgewildert wurden hat ihren ersten
flug gewagt zum ersten mal richtig luft
unter den schwingen bavaria hat den
wichtigen schritt in die freiheit
geschafft den vergangenen tagen hatten
sie und wally das fliegen immer wieder
fleißig geübt vor vier wochen waren die
beiden vögel in einer felsnische
gebracht worden und sind seitdem ganz
schön gewachsen
als nächstes muss jetzt wally ihren
jungfernflug wagen viel glück wieder
warnt der deutsche wetterdienst vor
schweren gewittern aktuell in teilen
nordrhein westfalens und von schleswig
holstein und gewitter bleiben uns auch
erhalten mehr dazu hat gleich katja
honnefer ich empfehle ihnen das heute
schon mal mit der kollegin marietta
slomka um 21 uhr 45
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da und
zwar sehr gerne vom gesamten team der
heute 19 in allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend was für eine hitze 41 grad
gab es heute in mostar in bosnien und
herzegowina
damit war es dort wärmer als in tunesien
die temperatur in west und nord
westeuropa lagen dagegen bei angenehmen
werden kaum über 20 grad viele dicke
weiße wolken sind sie da das sind zum
teil auch kräftige gewitter und die
breiten sich jetzt in der nacht vom
alpenrand weiter aus richtung erzgebirge
und auch morgen über tag gibt es noch
kräftigen regen und gewitter die
erreichen dann sogar schleswig holstein
heute nacht gibt es nur wenige regionen
in denen es ruhig bleibt hier im
äußersten nordwesten ist das der fall
und westlich des rheins machen sie sich
sonst auch starkregen gefasst es können
durchaus 40 liter regen pro quadratmeter
örtlich zusammenkommen und gewitter sind
auch dabei und die temperaturen dazu
bleiben laut besonders an oder und neiße
sinken sie nur auf 17 grad kühler wird
am alpenrand mit elf grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen dann
zwischen 19 und 25 grad und besonders im
osten müssen sie wieder mit starkregen
rechnen und auch mit gewitter im westen
sie ist etwas freundlicher aus besonders
hier richtung rhein und auch richtung
oberrhein und weiter geht's mit diesem
sehr wechselhaften wetter bei
temperaturen von 23 bis 30 grad am
montag bis bald